um some dude got accused of something
crazy so what did he get accused
apparently this woman and this man okay
but this woman she's a dancer and was
asking for money she also has a
5-year-old but her Alias is Rachel San
Antonio so this guy he gets a bunch of
hate texts from this girl he was around
and they were seeing each other he
wanted to stop seeing each other
essentially she goes online after he
wants to stop seeing her and puts him on
blast and says he gave her
HIV black Twitter picks it up everyone's
flaming this dude they can see who he is
everyone's going after him so some dude
near her calls her a cuz of all this
going on and he know it's false y'all
don't know how this man feeling whoever
saying it's false I keep saying it's
false he tagged me in okay exactly that
what I'm saying if we know it's false
everybody know it's false somebody need
to go on these Pages let them
know that it's F y' let just letting
this [__] drag on this
so everybody thinks that he gave her HIV
everybody's flaming him but it's false
she lied purposefully she lied yeah yeah
yeah she admits and that's what she's
admitting
to cool you could
play press play they get tarnished like
this it ain't right like you got to
clear this up you got to like No Cap you
got to clear this [__] up you you oliz
this man or something no no B this this
ain't it cuz now it's GNA come on you
now [__] ain't goingon even want
to [__] with you cuz you cuz now they
saying he got it now it's GNA say you
got it because they already said I got
it exactly so that's why I said all this
[__] just [__] that is so true imagine
being so [__] stupid you're that
hateful of a man that you claimed he
gave you HIV but it means that you have
it [__] are you stupid or you kind of
hit is is you dumb I I think I think the
both can
coexist cuz everybody who hears your
name afterwards like aren't you that
girl who got HIV from that one dude
who's creepy no that's not true what do
you mean it's not true I don't have HIV
but why' you say you have HIV cuz I lied
okay so if you don't got HIV you got
another mental disease cuz you out here
saying actually I'm not even going to
say you got a mental disease you just a
bad person let's not even bring mental
health it's not even that it's you lied
about having a HIV now you saying you
don't you got something worse you got
HIV y you you got what I call
personality AIDS what is that is that
when your personality try to disto dour
you yeah yeah yeah that's exactly what
it is out of all the things
yep he could have gave you he could have
gave you bad
credit you chose HIV uh yeah you want
revenge that's a great rumor to share no
it's not it is
if you want to harm someone's reputation
cuz this dude is getting dragged the
worst part is he came out he came out
with a video and he said here's my test
results this man had to run through the
STD cliar to prove to the internet
that's been slandering everywhere his
family friends all think he got HIV yeah
that's Revenge that's way better than
bad credit yeah but you know what they
say about revenge you know what they say
about pointing at somebody yeah whenever
you point at someone there's always
three fingers that pointed right back at
you so who gave you HIV if it's not him
no cuz you got HIV cuz you thought you
got HIV you got HIV look at these text
that she
faked look at these on the blue that's
her she faked all of that and she posted
him so everyone could find
them
negro first off that text conversation
looks super fake that looks like
incredibly orch rated text cont no but
you can't yeah but people are will buy
it people are not going to people are
not going to go and be like I'm not mad
at them going to be like o no cuz it's
fraud and fraud is meant to [__] get
people yes but it's bad fraud but I get
what you say it it works also we got a
Discord be sure to check that out or
Reddit too we don't play check them out
no R Reddit is popping I be checking out
I get topics from there all the time
this man has come out with test and
people still think he's he's guilty so
hey yo send this ass to jail send her
ass send it send it so what happened
send it cuz you guys want what do you
mean what happened to her
nothing what you think he's got the
money to set up a lawyer to slander her
that's not what I'm saying but so so
nothing she's just just just it's just
in the air all my days you can't sue her
just she sleep on the air mattress just
the oxygen is worth more than her
belongings in the air mattress that's
Abba I'm
preach and ABBA is all for
um you know yeah I don't wish no hell on
people and every you said that in
another video you did you did say that
what was the context what was the
context um yeah sure there was a context
in there
um I wish everything bad on you
everything that should happen bad on you
it should happen and you deserve it if
it happens get it eat it and that's that
I wish I if anything bad happens to you
I am not going to feel any type of
weight to me it's just going to be that
you know why we have a justice system
you know we have a justice system right
it's to
substitute for something better than
revenge yeah when there's no place for a
justice system to be involved you think
I don't understand the feeling of
Revenge yeah it's like the system failed
you someone caused you irr IR reparable
harm you can't sue them you can't even
take them to Criminal Court really even
if you sue them you're going to lose so
much suing them and you know it's wild
it's like you know a rumor back in the
day might have [__] you up with your
local community whatever it is now
anybody from anywhere can start a rumor
about you and it can [__] up your entire
life could [__] up your employment
opportunities your future dating your
family with your reputation and it's
like how you going to prove to everybody
you don't got nothing you can't just
constantly walk around with a test in
your hand cuz it's embarrassing to even
have to have that conversation people
will still doubt it's fake cuz some
people saw the test and he thought he
was faking it yep yeah because people
are going to use juicy over truth
sometimes it's like deep fakes it's like
we don't have laws in place yet to
protect people from the new technologies
and the way that we're using them to
slander people to harm people to hurt
them in ways that are actually worse
than physical I'd rather get my ass beat
then have to deal with what this man is
dealing with
100% yo I have three [__] run up on me
and beat my ass parking lot don't care
even if I'm losing some bones I could
heal from that I could never never fix
my reputation out there in the streets
never that is disgusting so yeah yeah
and I don't it's not even a gender thing
at all to me you could do this about a
woman it's disgusting oh
100% no it's not a gender thing be man
and woman right now yeah and yeah no you
can't fix that absolutely not you can't
do nothing about that and it's crazy
online people saw the text message and
they ran with it and they just enacted a
retribution for her because online the
frenzy for making Justice happen is you
are a bad person straight up there's no
good in you you are a bad you are a bad
personally but let's bring it back to
what you said you wish everything
terrible on him on her people had that
same emotion towards him when they saw
the 100% so that feeling that you have
is not good and that's why we have the
Justice understand you understand but
I'm more willing to wait than others to
have the real truth and everything and
stuff but that is foul
you did a whole and all the people who
participated online you're complicit yep
you can't just drop it you owe someone
in apology y mhm well she lied to the
public true she did but you contributed
you contributed you contributed nobody
told you to go dox this dude to go
harass him because of this whatever you
might have felt yeah cuz you wanted to
feel like you could rectify some sense
of Injustice in this world you
participated and now you're causing more
harm I'm not going to do the harm but if
something bad happens to you my girl
yep and it's just Tuesday morning all
right Jesus crazy story I saw just
wanted to share with you guys Jesus let
know what y'all think Jesus